[Music]
so i saw this on uh watching say i saw
it on tick tock but i don't have tick
tock but someone
said your child is a huge tick tock fan
that's the thing that's what it is
james producer loves tick tock no okay
so this is kevin o'leary shark tank
and here's his advice
i tell women today do not merge your
account with your husbands ever in your
whole life he will respect you for
having your own money let him have his
and set up a third account when you
merge your dollars together there's no
reason you have to give up your
financial identity when you marry
wow
no reason to give up your financial
identity
i don't even have
okay guess here's okay i don't even know
what to say to you no i well i have so
many places i want to start okay number
one let's let's just do this real life
rachel i we were we were out to dinner
with two couples that we know
and both women
work
and so that right they're a dual income
family
and both of them both of the guys what
well sorry one of the girls she pulled
back from work right she's like i'm
gonna i'm pulling back uh so she's she's
home with the kids and they have
school-aged kids and she's just home
and he's kind of like oh and she says i
i feel like i'm missing something for
the contributing to the household
because we hear that a lot all the time
contributing to the household and he's
kind of given her a hard time because
he's like you have a great brain like
you could use the brain and make money
you know this whole thing and so there
is this this
position when you are married and a wife
and a husband and you're there and
you're talking about money
uh lots of different perspectives right
that you can go into but when it comes
to just sharing the account like just
the just like we're just going to go
baseline that all of your money goes
into one account right
why would you not
except for if there's an if there's an
abusive situation you've got a divorce
on the horizon and you know like yeah or
you've got to create a pocket for safety
right yes yes
um but for majority of couples out there
functioning just in marriage and they're
just living their lives so what i take
from that call is this
i want to get married to somebody i want
to do
i want to join lives together
but i want to stay completely and
totally autonomous and still be quote
unquote just me
and then i'm going to be me you be you
and then we'll do this together thing on
the side or maybe we'll do it in the
middle but i'll be me on the side and
you on the side and so i'm going to keep
my loan identity here you keep your loan
identity here yep and what that is
called is a corporation that's a
business arrangement yes i'm gonna go to
my house you go to your house you go to
your side of bed and then we'll do this
job together and that's not marriage no
and and it's more vulnerable i mean back
to the other call we had on the last
segment there's a vulnerability to say
i'm going to give everything to you yes
and we're going to go in this marriage
together and we are going to be one in
every aspect and so let me push back on
this
again yeah clearly a super successful
financial financial person
i
i
i have never heard a man say you know
what i would really respect my wife if
she were less connected with me and more
independent and
you don't hear that kind of language you
hear the opposite i feel completely and
totally alone in a bed i share with my
partner yes i feel completely and
totally alone at dinner with my wife and
kids or my husband and kids because we
are not you're not unified in what we're
doing in our lives like the connection
point of where we are as a state
relationally yes
should say something exactly that what
what we're doing as a world
with merit
it's not working yeah so like so let's
just do the opposite of what the world
is doing and then maybe aka unite but no
and so i i like oh yeah so
i'm trying to find them real quick but
all the all the comments just all the
comments like doesn't work if someone
has bad spending habits i totally
disagree rachel this is unbelievable
advice
uh i told you i told you uh
oh my gosh
i don't agree we had joined accounts at
first and then he just kept spending and
spending then my kids and i couldn't eat
didn't have like basically didn't have
didn't have money for food so we
separated uh so again there are issues
that people have but money is not
the reason oh someone's like oh i
splurged and got a prenup so now
everything is separate this feels much
better for me and our marriage we go on
and on but but like there yeah there's
just this this idea that if there are
issues in the marriage right he is
spending everything and won't go to
therapy or
um you feel like you have a level of
your your identity still that it just
feels safer over here if i just keep
this stuff and you go there right like
all of that that's not a money issue
like that's a those are marriage issues
and it's coming out as a money issue
that we won't share accounts right but
it's indicating something deeper yes of
what's going on in the marriage
absolutely and you
money becomes the proxy and so if i'm
talking to a couple who's considering
getting married
and they won't share accounts
the issue is less about the function of
a checking account right it's more
this will never work if you go in with a
wall build and he goes in with a wall
built and you try to build a community
together it will not work
you have to decide it's the
vulnerability i'm going to open up the
drawbridge i'm going to open up the
gates here and we're going to get both
leave and we're going to go create
something new together
and god almighty dude the lowest con i
mean the simplest thing is to throw all
your money in the same account right
yeah if you can't figure that out
think long and hard about getting
married if you are married to somebody
who is prohibiting you and your children
from eating
that is abuse yeah right
go get help make a phone call that's not
about sharing a checking account
together that's about abuse yes right
that is a totally different product
because there are issues there are
situations like that absolutely that
we're not just like blindly know
regardless of anything no with if there
are there's major dysfunction in the
household and you have to protect
yourself for a reason
again huge marriage issue there but
there's ways to protect it yes
with your money because on the flip side
the positive of when you join your
accounts together as a couple that we
have found is that when you do something
together like money that's something
that is just hard in life and and
figuring out money or walking the baby
steps getting out of debt like this is
not easy stuff you really will have to
intentionally work at it but when you
have a spouse next to you and you guys
lock arms and you see yourselves as a
team and you say we're in this together
not only do i think that you you you
achieve your financial goals so much
faster when it's that mentality like we
are in this together and we're gonna
we're running the same race
but something happens there's a there's
a level of just uh excitement and
sacrifice all of that you do together
think about the basketball player that
says i don't care about y'all i'm going
to get my 30 points a game that team's
not going to win yep right it's when
they all say we're in this together
we're going to all give we're going to
all pass we're going to all shoot the
ball we're going to all play defense so
that we all win yeah right in the same
way it works and in a very kind of
shallow way too it the connection point
is there because you end up talking
about everything you have to talk about
it so you're talking you're
communicating which is a point of
connection so that's good
this is the ramsay show